mention valentine's day if you haven't
figured out your valentine's day plans
or gifts this weekend
we have some tips for you today starting
with a sci-fi themed date night
rocky is live in the twilight zone hey
rocky
here we go hey you guys okay we're gonna
start valentine's week
with a hole-in-one
that was my little joke for the week
okay guys all right we're here at
monster mini golf this theme is
sci-fi obviously if you could not tell
if you take a look around here
it's a little trippy i thought there
were mirrors and there are no mirrors
it's just kids and mini golf and
christina you were the founder and owner
of this
really cool place just tell people what
they can do here and what this is all
about
well we are 18 holes of black light
twilight zone themed
mini goblins bowling we have arcade
games yeah the trivia on the course
it's just a fun place all ages all ages
i see a lot of kids here but what we're
talking about is valentine's day so this
is
also doubling as an adult date night
right oh absolutely at night time it's a
lot of folks our age and it's a lot of
first date nights
it's a great birthday yeah so do you
have any fun stories about how people
have had their first dates here yeah
we've had a lot of because we have
monster mini golf all over the country
yeah so we've had a lot of folks do
their first date here and then we've had
a lot of proposals that monster really
got into it they're very cool
that's so cute how do they propose here
do they put the ring in the
in the ring in the hole or they buy a
golf ball they had the golf ball printed
will you marry me stop it
and they dropped that in the hole and
they built yeah daddy's so cute let's go
down on one knee
right right okay so tell people how they
can come celebrate with you guys for
valentine's day you can come here at any
time
seven days a week from noon to 10 a.m
and we're very affordable we're only ten
dollars
ten dollars wow that's perfect pandemic
date night and it's safe obviously as
you can see everybody's social distance
plenty of space out here
very easy you can make reservations too
so you can actually space please pay
somebody out by reservations as well
awesome well thank you so much christine
i'm going to play a little golf here and
coming up in the 4 o'clock we're going
to show you where people can actually
have a wedding a sci-fi wedding so stay
tuned for that
oh thank you rocky that looks like so
much fun we will check back in with you
during that 4 p.m newscast